i feel like
i should try to argue against anarchism
at some point out of love
out of love and so because people out of
joy
people enjoy seeing me um
what is it when like ben shapiro's
argues against like a 20 year old
feminist
destroys high school students this is
this video of uh michael males destroys
uh a a marxist russian communist
pig so anarchism is opposed to
hierarchies
well that's left anarchism yeah
anarcho-communism yeah it's a state but
there are many hierarchies that are not
the state
you we have a hierarchy here this is
your show on differential to you right
but there
okay rigid hierarchies forced
hierarchies is the time yes
forced hierarchies okay so do you think
it's possible that
humans when left on their own accord
they they form hierarchies naturally
yes inevitably inevitably which is why i
disagree with the left anarchist
i think it's not a coherent thing to
argue for
uh non-hierarchical relationships even
in theory it doesn't make sense to me
and i i know the the the old school
anarchist will call me stupid or
uninformed but i i've never been able to
even wrap my head
around this claim that you could have
relationships with that hierarchy right
so
i guess there's a certain sense in which
we're living in anarchism now and i
don't mean just like because the
the nations as you've said are uh in
anarchism
relative to each other but isn't the
united states just a collective that was
formed
in anarchy and this is just the
collective that we're
operating under this hierarchy that was
naturally formed it wasn't well the
united states was naturally formed it
was formed by force and and by fiat
but to your point um i i stress this
throughout the book
uh i always say this anarchism is not a
location it's a relationship
so yeah you and i do have a hierarchy in
that this is your show
but nine but neither of us really has an
authority over the other like i'm here
voluntarily you can kick me out if you
want
i can leave it anyone neither of us has
the power to force the other to be in
this relationship we've chosen
my lawyer uh you know i defer to his
judgment he's not forcing me to do it he
gives me his advice
and i could take it or leave it same
with the doctor so there is a clearly
like who's in charge and who's not in
charge
but they're not in a position to impose
their will and everybody else and you
could very easily see
john is stephanie's lawyer and stephanie
is john's doctor
and in each of those contexts one has
this position of ostensible authority
over the other so
anarchism is in fact not some utopian
crazy thing
it is the norm of human relationships
where you meet people
you're not necessarily equal someone's
gonna be taller someone's gonna be
stronger someone's start smarter
wealthier with others
but you're not at all thinking i am here
and i could tell you what to do and you
are legally or morally obligated
to follow my wishes that that is the
basis of anarchism
so in what way is the united states
imposing
by force something on you do you think
uh if you leave your house you will go
to jail
uh 40 my money being taken from you by
taxation
right but don't you have the freedom to
not operate under that
no but that's like yeah like technically
if someone comes up to you and
mugs you and says your money or your
life you are making a choice
but what the anarchist argument is
they're not a position to force you
to make that choice that is not morally
binding even though they have
practically the power
to force you into that dilemma but you
have the freedom to live
on the united states or not so so even
yeah the argument is if you don't like
it leave right not necessarily leave
like geographically but there's
there's ways to live outside
the force of the united states there's
ways it's just very difficult to operate
that way but that's like saying you can
outrun the mugger which is true
but the issue is does that mugger have
the right
to tell you at gunpoint you're either
giving me your money or i'm gonna shoot
you or
secret plan c you get to run away is
that person a
moral actor and the anarchist answer is
never and the difference
one more thing the anarchist view is the
difference between that mugger
and the government is only an air of
legitimacy literally they're morally
identical
so is it possible that every hierarchy
that gets big enough
and successful enough such that it can
monopolize
a bunch of services it provides isn't it
always going to be
a moral in your sense the way the united
states government is immoral well i i
don't want to say
just like the united states government
is immoral because that implies the
united states government is uniquely or
especially immoral very governmental
i just want to clarify that because i
know you didn't mean that and i don't
want that to be an implication
um can you repeat the question so like
won't every okay so that's right this is
so that's progressive economics yeah so
the argument is in any market
at a certain point things tend to
centralize and then that
organization de facto can dictate price
can dictate so on and so forth
that is completely historical if you
look at any market
the trend is always towards
decentralization
the music industry right when we were
kids there were four or five record
labels
they were the ones who made all the
songs that you're going to see in the
billboard top 100 with a few exceptions
now anyone can go to direct to market if
you look at tv stations right it went
from cbs nbc abc
then you got fox then you had cable
which is 100. now you have satellite
which have sounds around the world and
you have youtube which is literally
infinite
so as technology improves and as wealth
increases which is a function of free
enterprise
you are going to always have more and
more choice
even within a monopoly coca-cola right
uh
this is an example i used i think of the
new right when we were kids every
terrible comedian would be like
oh now that i've got diet uh
caffeine-free coke what's next and it's
like
yeah that's good you want to have what
was his name
uh uh cayman the guy who invented the
segway if you go it dean came in if you
go into
some um restaurants right now you will
have
those machines where you have like 80
kinds of cokes
and then you could have whatever flavor
you want to add to it grape cherry lemon
lime
so on and so forth so in any field
you're going to have more and more
competition you're going to have
less competition and less choices when
the state gets involved
because the state wants control the
state wants one big neck
with one leash around it and that way it
could just pull that dog in one
direction another
and you saw this last year with the
lockdowns carol roth wrote this amazing
book called the war in small business
and she talked about we have seen for
the first time in history
a massive wealth transfer from small and
medium business towards organizations
like target and amazon
who made trillions of dollars last year
whereas mom and pop which to me at least
is like the acme
of american achievement you come to
america you have a fruit stand a
laundromat
uh you make you socks whatever it is
you're that unique artisan creating
something special
they're the ones who didn't last whereas
target and amazon did so when you have
the state involvement
it will always be in favor of jeff bezos
and for the simple reason that
it's going to be a lot easier for jeff
bezos to get nancy pelosi and mitch
mcconnell on the phone
than it is for me making socks on etsy
but
your sense is that there'll be less and
less over time
jeff bezos says like whatever the
industry will look at
there's be less there's a trend towards
decentralization
across all industries and when i say
decentralization i just mean choice
right so if you look at again networks
you're gonna
if you were in the 80s and you had a
network just for uh lgbt issues
first of all it's going to be completely
heretical that's not going to happen
and there's not going to be enough
necessarily people identify as that to
have an audience
then there was something called logo
they have that there's lots of other
shows like that in this way
so more specific look at websites
i'm positive that you and i if we wanted
to look up
uh breeding guinea pigs would find
thousands of websites about different
breeds and all this other stuff
20 years ago 30 years ago like you're
gonna have two books
yeah and they're not gonna be dynamic as
these new uh breeds are developed
so at the same time it does following on
your argument
it does seem easier to move and
immigrate
from from state to state within the
united states and to other countries
do you think that's a form of freedom
that
embodies anarchism where you can resist
the uh the force of state by choosing
where you live
to some extent but the line people some
of these boomers will go up me on
twitter if i'm going after the police or
something and be like if you don't like
america
get out of here and i tell them freedom
means i do what i want not what you want
freedom means i don't have to move
you don't have to move free speech is a
good example it doesn't mean i have to
be on twitter right
twitter has the right to ban me but what
i'm saying is i'm saying something
and you don't like it too bad you're the
one who has to accommodate me
because i have a right to do what i want
with my person as long as i'm being
peaceful
so i guess i'm trying to get to the
difference between
the state and what you would naturally
want
in anarchy which is like a security
company
sure all those things they will
as they become successful start looking
more and more like the state
because you get to elect you give them
money
they they uh i got you they have leaders
what's the difference between
a government and a very successful
service provider in in anarchism this
gets a little confused in america
big companies necessarily are in hand in
hand with
the government ended up in bed with them
the answer to this question is a
long complicated one and thankfully it's
all in the anarchist handbook
there was an essay by murray rothbard
who dave smith this is the essay that
converted dave smith
so maybe it's not as good as it could
have been otherwise called anatomy of
the state
and mary rothbard points out that state
is the only
agency in a country which gets its goods
through force the state is the only
agency that is not a producer
but inherently a parasite because it
does not get its money voluntarily
but through taxation and by imposing its
values on a country
that is what makes a state uniquely
different from let's suppose an amazon
or a barnes noble or a target jeff bezos
does not have the authority or the moral
legitimacy
to get an army and go into somebody's
house whereas uh andrew cuomo
or ron desantis donald trump and barack
obama certainly do
but is it possible that
to reframe so jeff pesos does if he
if he hires a security force right also
is it possible to reframe taxation as a
form of payment like it
uh if it was done much better if you
could pay
this collective that we call government
in ways where you could pay for things
that you care for
so much your money would be much more
directly contributing to the things you
care for
whether if you care for a service like
healthcare you'll be able to
buy essentially insurance from the
government uh why am i buying insurance
from the government as opposed to
insurance from insurance company
what do you perceive as a difference
between a tax and a price do you see the
difference
yes i know on the surface level i'm
trying to get deeply to say
there's a lot of similarities but what
i'm saying is there's
one essential difference which is taxes
are imposed on you
and you have no choice as here's an
example my my book ego and hubris my
biography
it goes for 500 on ebay someone paid for
it some crazy person
people were showing me that it's on
amazon for 3 000
or something like that you could put a
million for it it's you could charge
whatever price you want the question is
is someone paying that 3 000 ford is
someone paying that million for it
and if it's actually the buyer who
establishes the price
because the seller can put any price tag
he wants 80 trillion dollars
but unless someone's paying that amount
and clearing the market uh that price
has literally
no real meaning right it's not an
indicator of value or worth or market
price
taxation on the other hand is by fiat
i can decide it's fair that you lex have
to pay 40
and joe has to pay 45 joe and lex are in
no position to be like this price is too
high
that not only is that money uh set just
completely out of their hands
it's taki for people who are employees
it's taken out of their paychecks before
they even see it
yeah they don't have the choice to be
like you know what i agree that the
government has the right to pay taxation
here's my check for 40 it's going on
it's a completely different
uh paradigm than you are when you're
paying for this so the government
provides a lot of services
in the current system right but there's
no service the government provides that
cannot be
that would not be provided better more
efficiently and with more choices in a
market
well that's a hypothesis no that's very
likely no well that's not
this i could demonstrate this to you
very easily
i love it when you get flustered this is
this is this is what people like it's so
cute
the robot don't make me put on the head
robot has the fire
the smoke coming out of his ears what is
price
[Laughter]
there okay so will tax love you know
like you know people like
i i think of uh the government as a kind
of subscription service
no no that's the anarchist view the
anarchist view of gov of
a private security would be a
subscription service so that's exactly
correct but everyone hates
when uh you sign up to a gym and then
you realize in the contract
it's very difficult to cancel that uh
membership and then they upped the price
i mean that's there's a lot of
unpleasant things with with uh with a
subscription service
that then you can elect to go to another
sure you're or you could go and yelp and
complain and if there's enough people to
do that the gym will be receptive
look at the power of yelp versus the
power of the vote well this
we could talk about that too so you're
saying yelp is more effective
than voting yes the thing is
i agree with you but you go
take a further step you say that yelp is
ethical
and moral and voting is amoral or like
not voting but
government is immoral so like it's not
only is one more efficient than the
other
you're saying like because i would say
government sucks
at doing what it does and it's gotten a
lot better at it
and i believe it can get keep getting
better
as it gets smaller and leverages
companies more and more
but you're saying no no government is
fundamentally as an idea
gets in the way of companies that should
be doing those things anyway
right i i just think that companies when
you take away government will start
looking like government
they just because something looks like
something does not mean it's the same
if someone puts out a yamaka into
fill-in and they go to shul they're not
jewish
right the the basic objection you have
with government
because you can leave like i i i
apologize that
this is that stupid twitter cliche
statement but
your opposition to the this idea of
leaving the united states
is that it's just it's a lot of effort
it's
it's it's too much friction not the
opposite the option the opposition is
i in the introduction to the book yeah i
say anarchism can be summed up in one
sentence
you do not speak for me everything else
is application
so the claim that somebody i've never
met or who i voted against
let's say i hate donald trump i despise
him
you know i want hillary clinton to be
president too bad trump's your president
that's not what i want the idea that
this person can come on me
and make any claims onto one second of
my time as opposed to trying to persuade
me
that is something that i and anarchists
regard as inherently
uh evil and nonsensical but to operate
large
organizations like you you see this with
cryptocurrency there's governance
you have to make difficult decisions
there's a block size wars for bitcoin
sure so you will there is a voting
mechanism often with membership when
your subscription service
but see the thing is you're using these
words and you're switching definitions
because like
if i go to a store i can technically say
i'm voting for tropicana orange juice as
opposed to another one
but to kind of say oh well you're making
a choice therefore every choice is a
vote i i don't i think that that's
something that
the venn diagram is not no i literally
mean vote in this case not money
okay there's some decisions like should
bitcoin
have increases block size okay there's a
bunch of different
uh they're called soft forks they're
hard forks oh i'm not saying you should
never
vote like stockholders have to vote
right exactly but there's no
pretense here's let's look at this if
you want to build robots
right you would sit down with the
company you would you guys would be like
we should do this kind of rubble i
should do this kind of robot
the stockholders would have a vote or
the board in proportion to their
investment in the firm
me who knows nothing about robots uh i
am
the idea that i'm in a position to walk
in and be like this is what you should
do
is crazy and bizarre and wrong because
i'm not in an informed position
so what democracy does is it forces
people who
run businesses well to run businesses
poorly
by people who don't know how to run
businesses at all that's the
that's one of the many concerns but
you're saying that's the fundamental
property of the state
uh i have a sense that the state could
become as effective as what we think of
as companies i mean
as this is why they can't because the
state does not have access to
data the way that firms do and this is
one of ludwig von mises great points
what he called the calculation problem
if i'm looking at comic books right and
i have detective comics
if detective comics 26 is a thousand and
detective comics 28 is a thousand
and detective comics 27 is 50 000
that is telling me that even if i don't
know anything about comics
that detective comics 27 is either very
very scarce for some reason
or very very desirable it's the first
appearance of batman whatever but
you don't need to know that to just look
at this data and be like okay this is
the market tell me something
if prices are set by the government
which the government is a monopoly
i have no way of picking those winners
or losers i don't have that data of
supply and demand
of an entire nation or a world of people
making individual decisions
and having price be dynamic and
informing me
as the the organization where i should
allocate my resources
so the price is a really strong signal
yes that allows you to uh
to operate a voluntary collective where
people get what they want
and don't get what they don't want and
it tells me what to produce
what not to produce and it also is great
because if i see this podcasting
industry which didn't exist five years
ago
and now these people are making bank
that tells me as
someone who is an investor okay they're
making 50
profi whatever 10 profit on their
capital in in the
plant industry it's two percent if i i'm
going to
further my capital into this 10 percent
and that's going to lower the profit
rate as as that uh builds up
and that is how uh markets are regulated
voluntarily
but the word government i just think
it's possible
to have collectives that of human beings
that represent
others based on their voluntary
yes of course you have private
governance absolutely private governance
any company you can have a ceo you're
gonna have a board directors yeah but
then you
i just it starts to
look very similar to me a successful
private
governance mechanism at a scale of the
united states
starts looking a whole lot like the
current government of the united states
what's g what's how
even amazon i don't think is anything
close to
the satellite size-wise or budget-wise
or power-wise
no so you're saying you just
it's not even state it's almost like
anything at that size you want to keep
things smaller
and i don't i their markets are not
going to
combine to that level of the state
because no
jeff bezos will never even position to
tell everyone in america
i'm going to take 40 of your money
before you even see it that to me is
actually unclear
we don't know that to be true or that
google or amazon
can't grow to the size if you take away
the us government i'm not sure that
amazon can't grow to the size okay so
worst case scenario is we're back where
we started right
uh that's not worst case scenario
so but the concern is that google is
going to be the federal government
that's not the concern i'm saying like
this is what it looks like when google
is the federal government it's not
it's like to me the
the us government is our best attempt so
far to have large-scale representation
of people's interests
it really sucks but it's our best
attempt so far and the question is how
to improve it
like if you take away all the if you
take away the us government
i'm trying to see how do we improve on
that
level that scale of representation of
people's interests let me give you one
example that's that
people could wrap their heads up very
easily i'm against government police
monopoly
i'm for private security right you don't
have to be an anarchist to understand
this
can everyone agree or at least as a
hypothesis
everyone can wrap the heads around and
here's a big concern 9-1-1
right there i've heard this 9-1-1 call
it's very chilling there's a kid in a
closet his family's being murdered
outside right he has to call 9-1-1 he's
whispering
it's horrifying to hear there's no
reason
why the number i call for my families
being murdered
is the same number i call for the fire
department is same number i call for an
ambulance
what if instead it operated like uber
you had buttons on your phone
if there's a real emergency like
someone's gun flyers someone's being
killed you press this
and it sends instead of the one police
district
whatever company is nearby you have a
bunch of them and they're the ones who
are going to come to your house to save
you
people can wrap their heads around that
very easily that is one
very clear way to go from having a
government security monopoly
towards having a more free enterprise
system so when you apply that to pretty
much anything it doesn't become that
complicated of alternative
so what i would you're gonna criticize
this
but i believe the government it's like
the parenting thing we've talked about
earlier
i think it creates a safe space
for govern for uh i look for safe spaces
so i'm not going to laugh at you about
that
no i want people to be safe but for uh a
safe space for entrepreneurship
so i believe that good government hold
on
give me a second give me a second sure
i'm sorry i'm sorry you're right you're
right i'm sorry
uh i think government gives a
uh opportunity for companies to
out-compete it
yes so yes fedex 100
not a question so i believe you need to
have private school government
to give a chance for ups fedex for
spacex
always an x in there uh to uh to to pop
up
and then government will naturally back
off from that place
so like you but you need the innovator
to step in and build the thing
okay like you can't just when has
government ever backed off though
that never happens back well from from
from what from fedex and ups from
spacex from amazon hold on
the u.s postal service still competes
with fedex and ups
so here's the other thing not nearly not
well but they still exist
and the point is they're dying but ups
and fedex are
taxed so not only are they paying for
their own company
they're paying for this competitor this
is the essential difference imagine if
you
didn't have ups excuse me federal
government no post office
so you had fedex you have dhl you have
u.s post service and many others
how about in this scenario ups
has the capacity to take 20 percent of
fedex's dhl
and courier's money and put in their own
pocket and they never have to do
anything in return
this is going to be an enormous
advantage of ups and then when you add
the addition that ups
is not necessarily going to be more
efficient than the others this is going
to be a huge distortion in the market
can you imagine if your podcast you just
automatically got 20
of the views of everybody else i mean
would there be any incentive for you to
be great or you could just sit in your
laurels and do whatever you want even
more than now
it's hard to imagine more than now i
didn't say you're a robot in lac
imagination
i i think there just has to be uh it's
of course you can
do it completely without government but
government here okay that's all i need
to hear show us over
the show's over with that government the
questions the questions
try the question is uh like that safety
net that's needed for entrepreneurship
that's needed for
oh i'm sorry to say but i have a sense
that there needs to be a bit of a safety
net for freedom
i i'm much more comfortable with saying
you need a safety net for freedom then
you need one for entrepreneurs
the beauty of markets is with your
startup if you have a startup and it
completely fails
the only person who's screwed is you and
your investors if i'm a government and i
make a startup the entire society fails
like the iraq war right if i have this
cockamamie plan i don't everyone else
doesn't have a choice they are both
funding it and sometimes even drafted or
forced into it right
the safety net the atlas getting back to
the early anarchists one of the things
that i
admire about them the inaugural
communists the old school left
anarchists
is people don't remember what context
they were in they were in context
without a welfare state
they're immigrating in huge numbers from
eastern europe people are you go to the
tenement museum in new york
people like 12 to room kids are working
factories or if they either work in
factories or they have to starve it's
not their parents didn't love them
it's that the parents didn't have birth
control which was a felony and they also
were in a position to put food in the
table for their kids because they're
uneducated
and the jobs are paying nothing so you
could understand why emma goldman
alexander berkman prodone
uh and and all these other figures were
like this is untenable
we see carnegie with 80 000 mansions
whereas
this lady whose husband died at age 30
who's never been to uh high school or
even junior high school
has 10 kids how is she going to put food
in the table it's not going to happen
you could understand why they would be
like all right we need to seize this
money
and distribute around the people that
makes a lot of sense in a contemporary
context
where food is much cheaper where shelter
to some extent
is uh more available when medical care
people we're so um
oblivious to how bad things were that we
see things are bad now so we assume that
they were better than in some context
they were much much worse there in many
contexts so
if you're going to make an argument for
government for me
the strongest argument is like food
stamps or like uh
free lunches for children because i
agree that would be very inefficient
and it's going to probably make them
obese because you're going to have
nabisco lobbing to make sure that if
you're going to have this
protein you want you're not going to
give the kids an oreo aren't you these
kids are
poor you want them to have some pleasure
and that's going to have deleterious
effects but if the choice is an
inefficient government program
and mass starvation that is one where as
an anarchist i have i
could easily see making the argument for
that one
even though i think very clearly private
charity would be more efficient and
distribute it more effectively but i
at that point i don't really care about
efficiency i if you're throwing out food
to make sure these kids get fed i don't
care so would the
engagement in military conflict be one
of the biggest
negative things about the state
to you yeah of course war is wars war is
the state at its worst
to take away war or make it defensive
instead of aggressive yeah i mean
wouldn't that be a huge step forward
yeah instead of regarded we're always
this is what drives me crazy
we're taught as kids in school that war
is a last resort
and i agree with that and yet in when
you look at the corporate press
war is always the first response and
these people do not talk about what
war means they'll show examples during
the
bush years of soldiers coming home in
caskets which
already is an unacceptable price in many
cases for me but
they don't even pretend to care about
the people overseas whose countries
we've ransacked
and lives were ruined and it's just like
well that what are you gonna do not
ransack those countries
so that war is it to me is the state at
its worst
see i think that there is value from
small government that doesn't engage in
wars i do think that
the kind of collectives that you imagine
functioning well would look like
the best version of government that i
imagine so okay
what a great endorsement well i see them
as the same
i think a lot of this is just
terminology i have no problem
saying that i'm using the word anarchism
incorrectly and
to go for what you want i have no
problem with that or anything really
because like i said life is beautiful
but
you